hello everyone and welcome back to the
couple Blanca saga has been a while
since we've checked up on good ol Jose
roll and well I don't want to repeat
everything what we've covered already
but just for your convenience I will put
a link to the description below if you
are new to this channel or new to the
couple Blanca saga do check it out all
of the videos that we've so far covered
will be in this playlist in the
description below now getting back to
this game ok before we get back to this
game I would just like to announce that
I have created and I got mater official
subreddit on reddit so if you are
unready to do check it out to do join to
subscribe to it and in commemorating the
creation of this subreddit actually I
also created an ask me anything post
well a thread so if you're interested
you can just really ask anything I will
answer I will be answering it for the
next 24 hours so you know do do enjoy it
if you'd like you can also create post
yourself ask anything you want to try to
educate others you can also post
something just for fun I prefer it would
be just related but if it's you know if
it's not offensive in any way or her I
mean if it's just well mannered then I
guess everything goes and you know just
meet people hang around and it's there
so yeah I mean feel free to use it yeah
I will put a link to it in the
description below it will be the first
thing you will see so welcome to to the
urban matter official reddit subreddit
and now getting back to this game last
time we were checking up on the couple
Blanca Saga we were checking up some
simultaneous exhibition games kappa
blanka held in Buenos Aires Argentina
now we are at the 1916 rice memorable
tournament in New York we still we're
still not covering the 1918 tournament
of New York but I decided to check up on
this one as there are a lot of exciting
games here and there are some very
strong players here some of the players
did not show up Alaska and Ian were
invited to the tournament but they
didn't come but all the strongest
players stronger players there is kapa
Lanka there's David Janoski Serbian
legend Borislav coast is she sir also
and really a lot of players similar to
the 1914 tournament
and Peterburg first they will all go at
it and then five of the most successful
players will go into a double
round-robin to see who's best I will not
be covering all of the games as it's a
really big tournament but those that are
the more exciting ones it's a it's a
tournament in honor of Isaac Leopold
rice before it was called the rice
memorial it was the rice gambit Isaac
Leopold rice started with the manual a
spur Alaska versus secretary for this
event and he was a multi-millionaire he
created 15 corporations he bought over
500 500 patents worldwide and he was
considered to be one of the world's
largest patrons considering chess so he
died in 1915 but even after his death he
said well he made sure that his widow
his the wife will take care of the
tournaments even after his death and
that there will be money always always
some enough money for chess which was
the case here and here in round one
kappa blanka faces an opponent that's
it's a very strong opponent mr. Roy
Turnbull black cabal Lanka already lost
a game against him also in New York in
1911 and here's Capablanca chance for a
rematch it's a we don't have a photo of
him which is very odd that's why I'm
wearing a hoodie as of course I'm
honoring the hoodie guy but Roy Turnbull
black nano not only was he's a very
strong chess player chess metrics
website rates him somewhere around the
top 20 players in those days but he was
also a judge as a profession so I was a
very amazed that I could not find that
there's a lot of information about mr.
Roy Trimble black and he lived up until
1962 so he lived a very long and well I
imagine wealthy life so it's very odd
that there is no photo of him on the
internet but you know maybe I'm just
asking too much I don't know yeah but
okay
that being said let's check out this
very nice game Capablanca has the white
pieces and he opens with E for and okay
with an e5 Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and
here Bishop to b5 the real opus is on
the board we have a six and the buzzer
a four-night to have six with castles by
Capablanca inviting the night captures
on e4 but Reuter will black knows his
theory and goes Bishop to e7
we have rook to e1 now strengthening d4
pawn d6 and now c3 preparing d4 this is
all standard stuff that's played even
today nothing really changed in in this
regard and also I forgot to mention
every month I usually mentioned this but
since it was the first of April I didn't
want to mention it maybe you think I was
joking or something but yeah as of late
I YouTube's algorithm will unsubscribe
you from a channel if you are not active
enough so do check it if you're still
subscribed to the channel maybe YouTube
unsubscribe you against your will so if
that happened you know feel free to join
back in but okay we have castles by
black not just by black by but by roy
Turnbull black d4 by Capablanca has he
did prepare it on the previous move and
b5 bishop the c2 still all pretty
standard stuff and now II capture some
d4 is not played black who goes to
Bishop to g4 instead and here as black
failed to capture on d4 capablanca takes
this opportunity to advance in the
center and grab more space we have d5
Knight goes back to be 8 and now h3
asking black what do you want to do with
the bishop of course black isn't
interested in giving up the bishop pair
bishop age 5 and now Knight bTW to the
standard maneuver you want to go night
if one IG 3 maybe III we'll see we'll
see what happens
Knight bTW 7 and knights to f1 as
planned we have rook to e8 and now not
immediately going night g3 or III but
first g4 Capablanca was never never shy
about pushing his g4 pawn butter up to
g6 end only now Knight to g3 were the E
and G pawn create a very nice outpost on
f5 for couple on last night if it will
be needed
h6 by black and now comes a 4 kappa
blanka with a nice flank attack against
the blacks advance the pawn structure on
the Queen side Knights - h7 and the now
comes Queen to e2 we have looked a b8 by
kappa blanka
pawn captures on b5 pawn captures on b5
and here
b4 just cementec that black pawn on b5
making it a constant target you will not
be able to defend it with the C pawn to
c6 c7 point is a backwards pawn it's a
weak point kaapa Blancas plan is to
plant play Bishop to d3 and then use the
Queen Bishop battery to harass the b5
porn also Luke is coming to a5 to help
out with an attack against the b5 pawn
and it's a very lonely pawn black will
have a very hard time defending it but
Roy Turnbull black is a very strong
player he finds away
he plays Queen to c8 and okay Capablanca
continues with his plan Bishop d3 we
have c6 now for the moment defending the
pawn but not for long
D captures and c6 Queen captures and c6
and now rook to a5 with a triple attack
against the b5 pawn mr. Roy Trimble
black is no longer able to defend it but
capablanca decides to give up the c3
pawn in exchange for the b5 point we
have Queen captures on c3 Bishop
captures now on b5 and Queen goes back
you don't want to keep your Queen there
for too long as it you know a white will
use a the weird position of the Queen to
harass her Bishop to e3 by Capablanca
now you can see that couple Blancas
bishops are really cutting cutting all
the way
very very nice bishops pear rook eat d8
now unpinning and here comes rook the c1
attacking the Queen on c7 Queen to b7
and here the material on the board is
completely equal both players still have
the bishop pair capablanca Kings
position is a bit more loose but
Capablanca has at one thing going for
him he has a passed pawn on b4 so how
does he how does he unwind here and
start pushing his passport well that's
the thing he doesn't here Capablanca
plays Bishop to c6
he decides to give up his pass bone
which you know he's capablanca he he can
do that but Queen captures on before but
there's no good way of declining this
offering if you don't capture the pawn
Queen c7 is pretty much your only square
Bishop b5 tribes the Queen Queen has
nowhere to go as Capablanca the bishops
are just monsters here and
the rooks are controlling the a and the
C file so it's actually not not a bad
position for for a thumbnail so I might
use that but after Bishop to c6 Reuter
Umbro black captures is on before we
have queen capture some before and now
looked a for the Queen hunt begins Queen
to b3 and now comes look to a7 a very
important move by playing rock to a7
capablanca now threatens twice the night
on d7 but also frees the a Foursquare
for his Bishop which will come in very
handy later
we have rook sorry we have Knight H to
f8 with now protecting the night on d7
twice and here comes Knight the d2
attacking the Queen but also the knight
will now be covering the c6 is C 4
square which will be very important as
you'll see Queen to be to buy black and
the now comes Queen to d1 and here the
thread is a rook to c2 but there is not
much black can do about it here you
can't move the knight that'd be great if
you could but you can't as the bishop on
e7 is hanging so here Roy terminal black
again a very resilient player he finds a
way
we have Bishop to g5 and here comes rook
to c2 and here a mr. Roy Turnbull black
has a problem the only square where he
actually could move the Queen his Queen
before but then comes as now the a
Foursquare has been vacated for the rook
rook to e4 and the Queen is trapped the
bishops still slicing all the way very
nicely the night covering very important
squares c4 and b3 the Queen has nowhere
to go and you just lose the Queen here
so here mr. black had a different plan
Bishop captures on e3 he gives up the
Queen but he gets a lot of material in
return route capture son b2 we have
Bishop capture Sunday 7 grabbing her by
Blancos roof rook captures on b8 Bishop
Kesari Knight captures on b8 attacking
the bishop on c6
and now just Bishop to d5 and here
Knights to e6 so if we count everything
what Roy Turnbull black garden I got in
exchange for the Queen is a rook and the
minor piece which is not all that bad
capablanca goes nice the e2 with
Knight to d7 and now Queen to a4 I
wouldn't attack against the bishop on a
seven
we have Bishop to be eight and now Queen
back to a - threatening to capture on e6
to win a pawn and also more material we
have Knight d2 c5 and now F three
strengthening d4 pawn now the knight
from d2 can move King to f8 and now
comes Knight to c4 and here we have king
daeso and just bringing that King all
the way to e7 to help out with the
defense of the night here and well it's
it's just a much safer Square for the
king
we have Knight to a5 and here for some
reason you have to avoid Knight to c6
check which will which will cost you the
rook but here mr. Roy turn will black
does it in a in a too active fashion
here rook the c8 would have been the
best move just getting the rook other
way and allowing this check but he
decided to play King to f6 and this is
maybe a too active square for the King
which Capablanca shows very nicely first
night the c6 check with an attack on the
rook and the bishop rook the c8 and now
comes h4 we have Bishop to c7 black
doesn't allow the knight to capture
anything and here comes the move f4 and
now black has some serious problems if
you capture the point you get Queen to
a-1 and it's checkmate not right away
black can block with the night but after
Knight blocks Queen captures this is now
checkmate the pawns are covering all of
the squares here Bishop covers the e6
and the night covers east 7 so the King
has nowhere to go this might actually be
a better thumbnail now that I think
about it
so after f4 we have Bishop captures on
e4 instead as the force pawn was
attacked twice but now Capablanca has g5
with Czech H captures we have H captures
and g5 and now if you go to g6 it simply
doesn't work just 97 check King to h7
and now you just move the knight let's
say Knight g3 and there is no defense
against Queen to h2 then I discovering
g8 and g6 so a checkmate will follow
very soon so after H capture H caps from
GF I would check
you have to capture with the night there
is no better better alternative
we have night capture Sun g5f captures
and King captures on g5 Bishop captures
Queen and night capture sunny for and
now Queen captures on f7 and now a black
will be able to grab the knight on c6
but it doesn't matter couple of Ankara
calculates precisely that it's safe to
capture the f7 pawn Bishop to b6 check
we have King to g2 rook captures on c6
but now just Queen captures and g7
capablanca so everything precisely King
to h5 and now Queen to h7 check picks up
the knight on e4 and if you're wondering
why not King to f5 check just to protect
the Knights than Queen d7 picks up the
story picks up the rook instead of the
night which of course is even worse Saul
King to h5 and then out comes Queen to
h7 check you want to pick up the night
King g5 Queen captures and rook the c7
getting the recovered way but now Kabul
Lanka has all the material he needs to
take this game to to an end 93 we have
King back to f6 now comes Queen d5 and
rush of the c5 guarding the d6 pawn
Knight the e4 check King to e7 and now
King to f3 Capablanca starts bringing
his King into the game with King d7 King
G for Luke the c6 and now Queen to f7
check King to c8 now comes Knight to f6
preparing to win the rope with Queen d7
check so rook the c7 attacking the Queen
Queen e8
check King to b7 and now Knight to d5
here look the c8 attacking the Queen but
Quinta b5 the Queen and Knight are just
you know a great team they're too
powerful King to a7 and here comes
Knight to e7 and it was in this position
that Roy Turnbull black resigns at the
game
unmoved 63 you know it's very unjust
like to resign a game on most 63 if
you're already almost 63 you might as
well play another move just to make it
64 I mean you are playing chess but yeah
okay why did he resign well there's
really no good defense against Knight to
c6 check whatever
playlet Saybrook c7 Knight to c6 check
now either lose the rook or you go King
gate and then checkmate will follow but
yeah now a very nice game by josé raúl
capablanca who still wasn't really you
know all that into chess studying and
everything but you know he's what he's
definitely a great player and it will be
a very interesting tournament which you
will see we're gonna talk about a bit
more about the players that are playing
here and the games that that happen
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it if you managed to find a
photo of mr. Roy Trimble black do deuce
just post a link in the description in
the in the comment section below so I
can share it with everyone I'm very much
interested to see what who this
gentleman was but yeah like I said
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
as usual you can check - in my previous
videos here I would like to thank you
only fly singer Jose Sanchez
Stefan Miller Jeff graves and FLC B
chess club for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
video sierra think all for watching and
I will see you soon hopefully with some
more interesting content changing upon
what's what continuing the capablanca
saga and you know checking up on your
suggestions and and stuff but yeah yeah
I check out to do that matter official
subreddit to do do you know
join in just you know come chill with
everyone is gonna be awesome and that's
that's pretty much it for this video
thank you all I will see you soon have
an excellent rest of your day